SPRINGER WANNA BE ANDERSON
COOPER.
THAT AND MORE IN TONIGHT'S
BREAKING NEWS OPENING MONOLOGUE.
IT'S OFFICIAL.
2018 IS THE YEAR OF THE
BOOMERANG.
OUR TOP STORY AFTER MONTHS OF
RINGING THE ALARM ABOUT THE
ABUSE OF POWER THE FACE FISA
COURT SYSTEM, THE DOJ INSPECTOR
GENERAL ANNOUNCED PLANS TO
INVESTIGATE ALLEGED FOREIGN
INTELLIGENCE SURVEILLANCE.
THE CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
DOSSIER FILLED WITH RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT LIES AND
MISINFORMATION WAS USED TO
EXTEND A FISA WARRANT ON CARTER
PAGE AND HOW CIRCULAR REPORTING
FROM YAHOO CITING THE PHONEY
DOSSIER WAS USED BY THE FBI TO
STRENGTHEN THEIR CASE AGAINST
PAGE.
SHOCKING CONFLICTS OF INJURY.
WE ARE FINALLY ONE STEP CLOSER
TO GETTING TO THE BOTTOM LINE
TRUTH IN WHAT IS THE BIGGEST
ABUSE OF POWER SCANDAL IN THE
HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY.
OF COURSE, WE DESERVE TO KNOW
THE TRUTH.
WE ARE REVEALING THE REAL AND
EVER PRESENT DANGER TO HAVE THE
POWERFUL TOOLS OF INTELLIGENCE
USED AGAINST THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
I THEN IS SLOW.
I KNOW THIS IS SLOW AND
FRUSTRATING.
WE ARE MAKING SERIOUS PROGRESS.
ACCORD TO THE DOJ, THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL SAID IN PART, QUOTE:
THIS IS INTERESTING.
ADDITIONALLY, THEY WILL REVIEW
THE DOJ'S FBI'S RELATIONSHIP
RELATING TO THE FISA COURT
APPLICATIONS.
THEY MUST ANSWER THESE
QUESTIONS.
JUST A FEW OF MANY.
WHAT DID THE FBI KNOW ABOUT THE
STEELE DOSSIER AND WHEN DID THEY
KNOW IT?
WHAT WAS THE FBI'S RELATIONSHIP
WITH A FOREIGN NATIONAL WITH
CHRISTOPHER STEELE WHO USED
RUSSIAN SOURCES?
WAS THE FISA WARRANT AGAINST
CARTER PAGE POLITICALLY
MOTEVIATED.
MY MESSAGE TONIGHT TO THE FBI
AND DOJ IS TURN OVER THE 1.2
MILLION DOCUMENTS THAT CONGRESS
SUBPOENAED.
IT'S TIME TO APPOINT THE SPECIAL
BECAUSE YOU CANNOT EVER
INVESTIGATE YOURSELF.
THIS BRINGS US TO OUR INCOME
BREAKING STORY.
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATORS FROM
THE FREEDOM CAUCUS HAVE
UNEARTHED EVEN MORE TEXTS
BETWEEN PETER STRZOK AND LISA
PAGE.
THERE ARE OVER 50,000 TEXTS.
THIS IS BUT A SMALL SAMPLING OF
WHAT THEY BELIEVE COULD REVEAL
DAMNING NEW EVIDENCE THAT THE
FBI, THE OBAMA WHITE HOUSE AND
THE CIA AND THE INTEL COMMUNITY
WERE ALL WORKING TOGETHER IN
ORDER TO OPEN UP A POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED TRUMP RUSSIA COLLUSION
INVESTIGATION.
WHY THIS IS IMPORTANT.
ACCORDING TO ONE TEXT MESSAGE
FROM PETER STRZOK TO LISA, HE
MADE A REFERENCE TO THE FIRST
MEETING DISCUSSING COORDINATION
BETWEEN THE FBI AND THE DOJ.
THIS IS THAT STRZOK WRITES.
THE CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATORS
BELIEVE THIS IS EVIDENT THAT THE
FBI AND DOJ MEANT TO DISCUSS THE
RUSSIAN ELECTION HACKING
INVESTIGATION.
AUGUST 25th, 2016.
HARRY REID WITH BRENNAN ABOUT
RUSSIAN ATTEMPTS TO INFLUENCE
THE ELECTION.
THEN HE SEND A LETTER TO JAMES
COMEY URGING HIM TO OPEN AN
INVESTIGATION INTO DONALD TRUMP.
HE WROTE AT THE TIME:
AFTER THE LETTER BECAME PUBLIC,
STRZOK TEXTED PAGE A LINK
REFERENCING THE LETTER, WRITING
HERE WE GO.
NEXT THE FBI USED THAT LETTER AS
LEGITIMATE COVER FOR THEIR
INVESTIGATION INTO RUSSIA
COLLUSION AND AS PART OF THE
FISA WARRANT APPLICATION AGAINST
CARTER PAGE.
A TRUMP CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATE.
THAT GETS THEM ALL OF THE EMAILS
AND RIGHT INTO THE HEART OF THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
IN OTHER WORDS, THIS WAS A
COORDINATED EFFORT TO SPY AND
BRING DOWN AND TARNISH THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
SARAH CARTER AND THE HOUSE INTEL
CHAIRMAN WILL BE HERE TONIGHT
AND EXPLAIN THIS TO YOU.
WHILE WE BRING YOU INFORMATION
ON THE DEEP STATE FORCES WORKING
TO TAKE DOWN THE PRESIDENT AND
MAKE SURE PRESIDENT TRUMP NEVER
GOT ELECTED, THE FBI IS STONE
WALLING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
CONGRESS WHEN IT COMES TO
REQUESTS FOR DOCUMENTS RELATING
TO 3 IMPORTANT TOPICS INCLUDING
CLINTON'S EMAIL SERVER AND FISA
ABUSES AND WHY MCCABE WAS FIRED
FROM THE FBI.
THE RELEASE OF DOCUMENTS HAS
BEEN EXTRAORDINARY SLOW.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, IT ALMOST
SOUNDS LIKE OBSTRUCTION TO ME.
SO SLOW THAT THE HOUSE JUDICIARY
CHAIRMAN SHOULD A SUBPOENA.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF
SESSIONS IS ABSOLUTELY LIVID
WITH THE FBI DIRECTOR WRAY.
GIVE US THESE DOCUMENTS.
IN RESPONSE, DIRECTOR WRAY
PROMISED TO DOUBLE THE AMOUNT OF
STAFF WORKING ON RELEASING THE
DOCUMENTS AND HE WILL DOUBLE UP
THEIR SHIFTS.
IS THIS TOO LITTLE TOO LATE?
SHOULD A CONTEMPT OF COURT ORDER
BE ISSUED IF THE FBI DOESN'T
COMPLY WITH THE SUBPOENA?
ANOTHER TOP STORY.
THE MEDIA ERUPTD ED INTO A
FRENZY TODAY OVER A STORY IN THE
"NEW YORK TIMES" SPECULATING
THAT "TRUMP'S LAWYER RAISED THE
PROBLEM OF PARDONS FOR GENERAL
FLYNN AND PAUL MANAFORT."
ONE TINY LITTLE PROBLEM WITH
THIS STORY.
IT'S FAKE NEWS.
ONE OF TRUMP'S LAWYER COBB PUT
OUT A STATEMENT THAT READS:
FAKE NEWS.
COBB COULD NOT HAVE BEEN MORE
CLEAR.
THAT DIDN'T STOP THE CORRUPT
MAINSTREAM MEDIA FROM OBSESSING
OVER THE STORY DURING TODAY'S
WHITE HOUSE BRIEFING.
WE HAVE THE EVIDENCE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ARE PARDONS ON THE TABLE FOR
ANYONE INVOLVED IN THE RUSSIA
PROBE?
>> I REFER YOU BACK TO THE
STATEMENT FROM TY COBB.
>> CAN YOU SAY NO ONE HERE
DISCUSSED PARDONS IN THIS CASE?
>> I CAN SAY TY COBB IS THE
PERSON THAT WOULD BE MOST
DIRECTLY INVOLVED IN IT.
>> DOES THE PRESIDENT BELIEVE HE
HAS THE RIGHT TO USE THE POWER
OF HIS OFFICE TO PARDON TO
PROTECT THEM FROM UNFAIR
PUNISHMENT DOWN THE ROAD?
>> I WOULD REFER YOU BACK TO TY
COBB'S STATEMENT.
>> IS HE CONSIDERING PARDONING
PAUL MANAFORT MICHAEL FLYNN OR
RICK GATES?
>> AS I SAID AN ON-RECORD
STATEMENT FROM THE PRESIDENT'S
ATTORNEY AT THE WHITE HOUSE SAID
FROM IS NO DISCUSSION OR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS.
>> DID THE PRESIDENT DIRECT JOHN
DOWD TO TALK TO THE ATTORNEYS OF
MANAFORT AND FLYNN ABOUT
PARDONS?
>> I AM NOT AWARE OF ANY
CONVERSATIONS.
>> Sean: EVERYONE ON THE PRESS
CORP APPEARED TO BE ON THE SAME
PAGE ON THIS THE BOGUS "NEW YORK
TIMES" FAKE NEWS STORY.
ONE REPORTER DID NOT GET THE
MEMO AND HE WORKS FOR FAKE NEWS
CNN.
JIM WAS PREOCCUPIED WITH STORMY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THANKS, HAVE A GREAT REST OF
THE WEEK.
>> STORMY DANIELS, WHY HASN'T HE
SPOKEN ON STORMY DANIELS?
>> Sean: THAT'S NOT SURPRISING
COMING FROM FAKE NEWS CNN LED BY
THE KING OF PORN JEFF ZUCKER.
AND WE LEARNED THAT CREEPY
ANDERSON COOPER, THE JERRY
SPRINGER WANNA BE WILL HOST'S
TOWN HALL WITH JAMES COMEY.
TO BECOME THE NEXT LIBERAL
TALKING HEAD.
JAMES COMEY, I ALREADY TOLD YOU,
YOU CAN DIVULGE YOUR DEEPEST AND
DARKEST SECRETS TO ME AND CREEPY
ANDERSON COOPER.
IT'S YOUR CHOICE.
THESE ARE SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
COOPER WAS ASKING.
JERRY SPRING JR. ASKING STORMY
DANIELS AND KAREN McDOUGAL.
CHECK OUT THE CREEP FACTOR.
>> THE SEX WAS CONSENSUAL?
DID HE HAND YOU MONEY?
DID HE BRING UP HIS WIFE OR
CHILD?
WERE YOU IN LOVE WITH HIM.
DID HE COMPARE YOU TO ANY OF HIS
KIDS.
DID HE USE PROTECTION.
>> YOU TOLD DONALD TRUMP TO TURN
AROUND AND TAKE OFF HIS PANTS?
>> YES.
>> DID HE?
>> YOU WERE 27 AND HE WAS 60.
WERE YOU PHYSICALLY ATTRACTED TO
HIM?
>> NO.
>> DID YOU WANT TO HAVE SEX WITH
HIM.
DID HE USE A CONDOM?
>> NO.
>> DID YOU ASK HIM TO?
>> AFTER YOU HAD SEX WHAT
HAPPENED.
PHYSICALLY YOU HAVE SEEN HIM IN
WAYS OTHER PEOPLE HAVEN'T?
>> CORRECT.
I HAVE BEEN ASKED TO DESCRIBE
THAT.
>> Sean: JIM COMEY GOOD LUCK.
GIVEN THE INVESTIGATION BY THE
DOJ'S INSPECTOR GENERAL ON
POTENTIAL FISA ABUSE, YOU MAY
WANT TO RETHINK THAT BOOK AND
BOOK TOUR.
JAMES COMEY, REMEMBER IN THIS
COUNTRY, DO YOU HAVE THE RIGHT
TO REMAIN SILENT.
YOU ARE STILL WELCOME ON THIS
PROGRAM, MR. COMEY.
WE WILL GIVE YOU THE ENTIRE
HOUR.
THIS IS THE HIGHEST RATED HOUR
IN CABLE NEWS.
I WILL GIVE YOU THREE HOURS TO
MY RADIO SHOW ON 570 PLUS
STATIONS ACROSS AMERICA.
IT'S TIME TO GIVE THE AMERICAN